no Eddie this is not gonna go well so
we've got some word now on actual
storylines that are influencing the
venom movie that comes out next year and
it's kind of a sucked away the little
hope I had in case you were wondering
that was spiked apple cider
I was tricky at the front end of this so
the word has come down that they are
drawing inspiration from to specific
venom related stories namely lethal
protector which was Venom's first solo
miniseries and also Planet of the
symbionts
I read people protector I actually have
leave a protector cuz yeah I was really
into venom in the 90s what do you want
from me I was ten but so I've read that
I can speak on that one specifically
plenty over the symbiotes I have not
read but just the fact that these are
the two they're pulling from it there's
one very simple common thread that they
have in both of them and that is simply
it's other than venom factoring in
generally as additional villains so leaf
protectors saw venom leave New York
which was where Spiderman was after
basically he said look I'll stop trying
to kill you but you can't chase me and
spider-man reluctantly agreed to that
and venom went off and did his own thing
he kind of became a little bit like The
Punisher cuz he he was doing the whole
protecting the wow the Punishers just
kind of killed the criminals so he was
like a split between the spider-man and
the Punisher cuz he was protecting the
innocent by killing criminals but
towards the tail end of that story he
got captured and then basically
spawn Simbi it's yeah the little sort of
seeds for new symbiotes were extracted
from him to make new ones and there were
I think I think there were six there
were five or six of them only one of
them was still around again at the end
of that story and even
then did I think only appeared one more
time this wasn't stuff that too many
people cared about it made for some neat
visuals but that's kind of about it but
to a certain degree it's not a totally
invalid story to pull from if you're
doing a solo
Venna movie that doesn't involve sprite
Ironman which is that even though
Spiderman actually appears heavily in
the story itself
he doesn't really impact the narrative
of it as much it is it is really venom
sari they just shove spider-man in a lot
because I would guess by editorial
mandate they were wholly nervous that
venom couldn't quite carries on book yet
now again planet assembly that's I I
haven't read but I'm pretty sure it's
it's basically an invasion kind of story
if I am remembering what I heard about
it but honestly the specifics don't
matter because it's not going to it's
not going to be a faithful adaptation of
either of these because really almost
none of the comic book movies that have
been made are specifically and
faithfully adapting specific comic book
storylines I mean unless is something
like Watchmen which only has the ones
door had the one story anyways until
recently but at my point being when when
heroes who have had long-running stories
about them generally they might pull
specific stories to pull influence from
but they generally haven't been
faithfully adapting them I mean when
x-men did Days of Future past it took
the gimmick but didn't even have the
same character going back in time
changed a whole lot of things Captain
America's Civil War was vastly different
but kept the heart of the idea of we're
gonna have the heroes butt heads and
there's gonna be a regulation thing kind
of at the heart of it so on so I could
keep listening examples but again they
they generally don't adapt specific
storylines like really faithfully so and
obviously these two stories don't
naturally feed into each other so I have
to zero in on the common thread which as
I said is to be it's other than venom
and there's a reason that I don't like
that because in my mind if you're going
to make venom as a solo character if it
is going to work at all it's going to
have any prayer then m'l they're going
for because they've said they want
something horror tinged and r-rated
which I
okay that can work in my mind venom has
to be the only symbiote in his first
movie because he has not been yes I know
spider-man 3 everyone wants to forget
about spider-man 3 modern era of comic
book movies basically you know since
Ironman we have not seen venom so you
have to establish him and you have to
establish what is special and important
about him and a really quick way to
dilute that it's to flood the screen
with a bunch of other people who can do
the same thing he can do that that
immediately devalues him it immediately
makes him less special and it's not
something that would be such a problem
if he was getting introduced in a
spider-man movie first and then getting
swamped because you know audiences would
have a chance to wrap their head around
this character on his own and then you
spin them off in these he's facing
others kind of like am i oh ok kind of
interesting but they've got to start
from the ground level here so if you're
not getting into you know his connection
with spider-man then you have to really
dig in to the link that he has with the
symbiote and I honestly I feel that's
where a lot of the horror should come
from it should be almost body horror
what is this thing doing to him how much
control does he have over that you know
have him go up against somebody super
power but not another symbol yet I mean
you can pretty much take your pick of
almost any villain I mean if they're
going to lethal protector right and he's
like protecting people from you know a
really particularly violent criminal
he'll you can have him take on the
scorpion you could yo you know would
work you could have him take on Alastair
Smythe and the spider-slayers instead of
him being obsessed with spider-man he's
obsessed with stopping venom and you
know he builds these machines to take
down venom in eventually augments
himself to try and take down but or you
know heck you could make up a villain
for venom to take on because again the
first movie should be about him pretty
laser focused and you can venom does not
have that many enemies unique to him
like he
had run-in with various characters in
the Marvel Universe but he doesn't
really have his own rogues gallery so it
doesn't really matter who the villain is
initially now a lot of people might say
well didn't we always know there was
gonna be other symbols didn't they say
carnage was gonna be in this they did
but the wording that we'd gotten up to
this point gave me a slight sliver of
hope which is that when it was announced
that carnage was gonna be appearing what
was actually confirm was the character
of Cletus Kasady who comic book fans
know will become carnage was going to be
appearing so my hope was that Cletus
Kasady the serial killer would get
seated and introduced hopefully not as
the main villain but would appear and be
established in this film maybe at the
very end maybe as apposed credits you
show his becoming carnage and then
second film is carnage versus venom
because once we establish a committee to
establish who venom is what makes him
dangerous what makes him interesting and
why we should be rooting for him but
also like give a little bit of you know
here's this Cletus Kasady guy as well
you know establish why he's dangerous am
i he's kind of nuts
give him similar powers in that in the
sequel that's just gonna meteor ramp up
of everything because we had this heat
this hero this violent hero who could
have spent the first movie largely just
grappling with himself die and come to
terms oh okay he's got it but now he has
to face something that is very much like
him but way worse than him that's a
natural escalation for a sequel but if
you throw somebody it's right off the
bat whether it's carnage or or any of
the others you just immediately again
you make venom himself less unique you
make him less special you make him less
interesting and that's not me saying
that simulator can never be introduced
down the line I just think that's a
really bad idea to do as a starting
point it feels like they're flooding too
much stuff in right at the bat which
Sony does a lot of I mean that was the
epitome of what went wrong with the
amazing spider-man franchise the second
one especially Sony does not and Sony as
a company does not understand that
sometimes less is more and that you just
need to you need to get the character
right and the more
flash and extra stuff you put in there
the less you are focusing on the
character the character that you have to
sell because he's not getting
established and in a spider-man movie
first so you have to get him right and
putting all this other stuff in I'm not
saying it's impossible to get it right
but I don't have the faith in Sony to be
able to juggle all this stuff and
actually deliver a well meaning
character I think that this movie should
be stripped down he should be the only
symbol it should be a relatively
contained budget we shouldn't have a ton
of CGI all over the place limit it to
just venom but the more I hear about
this and this especially I'm just
thinking you guys you're just gonna
flood the screen with a bunch of CGI and
there's gonna be 15 million babies
running around and there's gonna be a
friggin laser into the sky that opens a
portal to the symbiote planet is gonna
signal the invasion of more symbiotes
I'm I would not be shocked at this point
I just I don't know man I I never had a
lot of hope for the venom movie I
thought it was a stupid idea in the
first place but when I heard that I mean
I like Tom Hardy as an actor he's a he's
an okay pick him what I heard they were
going for a horror angle I actually
start to think of ways that it could
work I'm now losing hope with that
because you know what here's a good
comparison if they want to do venom as a
horror movie
venom needs to be alien and then in the
sequel you up the stakes because a lot
of horror is derived from stuff we don't
understand and the unknown so you have a
lot of questions about the simple how it
works can you get a hold of it so that
one is your alien really tightly focused
not overly grand or huge but really
zeroed in on the characters and the fact
that we don't know a ton about this
thing yet and then your second one then
you bring in a whole bunch more sim base
and that's your aliens which is not as
scary but brings up the spectacle level
you jump right to aliens immediately
then you don't have a lien and aliens
anymore you have Starship Troopers which
is a fine movie but is is not it's not
the same thing it's really hard for
anything going for a horror vibe to go
big right off the bat horror in my
opinion in my experience horror works
best small and self-contained if you
want to expand it out later
go ahead cuz that's a way to keep you
from just repeating the same thing over
and over you know like the slashers do
at nauseam but you go big immediately
and it's not scary it's too grand it
needs to be small it needs to be
personal we need to care and the more
sim baits you throw at the screen I for
one the less I'm gonna care so so
that'll do it for this one those are my
thoughts on the news about the stories
they're pulling from for the venom movie
did you hear this news er are you
hearing it from me god am i a news
source for people yeah that's a
frightening thought whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it not only
that stuff like scribe I've got a
podcast I've got two podcasts they're on
two different fees there's links down
below I'll try and shrink the outro a
little bit so you know what until next
time this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]